did you see the puppy do you like  puppies if you did i still smell like  puppies  so cute  it's hard for me to turn away i know i  know take them home  do you have puppies or cats um i'm  actually due for a puppy oh but um i had  of sound like you're gonna have the  puppy  like amazing  um i just have a lot of dogs and then  one by one they kind of you know passed  away and so i don't have any dogs at the  moment i do have a cat  okay stella she's a very special cat  and she shall she's but she would also  go with us yes  you have so do i yeah i had well i  actually  she passed away my my first and only dog  her name was well and this is a little  bit of her hair in my uh in my necklace  yeah oh that's creepy  i know i love that i love the whole  shrine to llewellyn  oh  people don't get it like i mean i have  kids too and i'm telling you they're  like a part of my face  one of my dogs i thought i was gonna die  myself it really literally  is love it's love  [Music]  you